I'm beyond unreal you are guys literally
the best fans around around I'm so
grateful that people think that I'm
worthy of their time just thank know
that I'm always grateful if I don't
follow through then I'm doing this for
the wrong reasons and the right reasons
are to try to build a community that can
help people so if you've got something
to do you got to hold on to him you've
got to keep at it you got to keep that
candle burning because if you let it go
out then you may never have another
chance again I've never cared about
anything as much as I care about this
channel it's the reason why I get up in
the morning and the reason why I stay up
late I just want to work on it and I
want to make content for you guys and I
want to do this for a long time thank
you so much for 2 million subscribers
these milestones have been coming so
quickly that I've barely had time to
cope with the changes that come with so
many new people enjoying my videos it's
insane and this one in particular caught
me by surprise because I thought that I
had at least a few weeks before we get
here and yet here we are 2 million
people strong there's a lot of things
that I want to say and you guys know I
can get kind of wordy with these vlogs
but there's one very important topic
that I want to hit as we celebrate 2
million and move into the future with
however many million we're going to have
there's one thing that I've gained a lot
of perspective on as I've done this for
almost two years and that is how much
I've grown as a person and that may seem
kind of strange because I know the
channel has grown in the community has
grown but a lot of people may know if
you've seen my draw my life or watched
my vlogs when I started my channel I
came into it from a very low point in my
life you know a lot of things were going
on and a lot of things were going wrong
and I wasn't very happy with who I was
and the kind of person I was and where I
was going in my life so when I started
the channel I threw myself into it 100%
every single waking moment
my life was dedicated to the channel and
making it better and making myself
better and making the content that I
produced better even though I wasn't
very confident in myself and even though
early on I had a very bombastic
personality that was flawless in every
way and so strong and handsome but in
reality there were so many doubts in my
mind of who I was and what I was doing
and why I was doing it but I just kept
at it with this constant unrelenting
idea that I could be a better person and
in a way that's who I wanted markiplier
to be that's who I wanted people to see
when they watched my videos I wanted
them to see me even though I had so many
downfalls and I had so many wrong points
in my life and I had so many things that
I wanted to change I wanted people to
see what I could be and it's weird
recently because I I see myself today in
a room in Los Angeles in a completely
different state across the country from
where I started you know away from the
friends that I've made but being able to
meet so many new people here and having
the opportunities to work with so many
amazing people so many talented
individuals and having these amazing
things happen in my life because of you
guys in the support that you've shown me
and the ability to do this because you
guys push me to do it and that's the
only reason I am able to because if I
had been on the internet and I had just
done that and there was no response I
don't even think that I would be a
better person today for it
my friends push me to be better and I
and I respect them so much but you guys
push me to expect more of myself and I
think that's more important than
anything like I'm not saying it's more
important your mind my friends or
anything like that but having the
introspective to understand who you're
gonna be in the future and knowing that
going forward you can be
you can do better or you can put
yourself out there and people will
believe in you is the most inspiring
thing that's ever happened in my life
and it's something that I am eternally
grateful for because not only have you
given me the opportunity to turn my life
around and you've given me the resources
to do the things that I want to do but
you've given me a chance to improve Who
I am as a person and above everything
above anything in terms of success for
the channel number of subscribers number
of views how much money I'm able to make
on the internet above all else I respect
who I have become and that is amazing
and I want everyone to be able to feel
that or be able to know that they're
comfortable with who they are and to be
able to believe that they have improved
over time and as I go into the future
that's what I want to continue doing
because I know this is not my peak this
is not going to be the best I am ever
going to be I still have flaws and I
still make mistakes but at least I have
the opportunity and ability to learn
from them and move forward from them and
that is what I want you guys to
understand and believe in your own
selves in what you guys do and
understand that you guys have the
ability and the passion and the
dedication to do whatever you want and
if nothing else you guys can at least
believe in the community that we've made
in the ability that it as an entire
entity can actually change the world
and that is the most amazing thing to me
so thank you guys so much for believing
in me thank you guys for 2 million
subscribers thank you for everything and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye